hey guys do you like eating oatmeal
oats well if you don't you probably will
after watching this video
because in this video i'm gonna share
with you five important things
reasons why men should eat more oats
let's get to it
[Music]
i have a dream that's all i
[Music]
i've need mistakes but mistakes make you
strong
now just very quick if you're new here
to my channel my name is daniel
and welcome now let's not waste any more
time let's start with the first reason
why men should eat a lot more oats
you will lose fat yes oats will make you
feel fuller
for much longer that's all because of
the healthy fiber and it's called beta
glucan
which regulate your hunger hormones so
you'll eat a lot less
why because you'll feel a lot more
satisfied after every bowl
of oats oatmeal also help us men with
our prostate
is true because it has an amino acid
called l-arginine
that relax blood vessels and boost blood
flow
a lot of guys who struggle with erectile
dysfunction
they get treated with this amino acid
but now you know that you can just get
it for free
in oats you will live
longer look carbs got a very bad rep
over the last few years especially
bread but don't throw away the good
carbs
like oatmeal it's really good because it
protects you against things like type 2
diabetes heart attacks and stroke
[Music]
another reason why you should eat oats a
lot more is because it fights
cholesterol according to the centers for
disease control and prevention
31.7 of americans have high cholesterol
that's 73.5 million people
now if only they ate more oats because
oats is full of fiber full of b vitamins
and it lowers
cholesterol oatmeal builds
muscle so you don't just need to eat a
lot of meat to build muscle but also
healthy good
carbs to help you with it like oats one
cup of oats roughly gives you around 300
calories
5 grams of fat 56 grams of carbohydrates
and 10
grams of protein and apart from this you
also get
1 gram of niacin meaning vitamin b3
and 3 grams of iron now if you're not
sure what these things do
vitamin b converts carbs into energy
and iron helps to transport oxygen into
your bloodstream
and into your muscles
now just a bonus tip if you don't like
oatmeal then try
different ways of preparing it then
you'll find out that you will actually
like it very very very important don't
eat it
without salt always add salt because you
don't
oh my goodness anyway also try it
without water you can add milk
or even yogurt and then build it the way
you like it you can add nuts bananas and
strawberries or
dried with peanut butter honey and
cinnamon or
add it into your whey protein smoothie
now all you gotta do is just play around
with it try different things until
you find what works for you now if you
want more mains tips like
how to increase your testosterone watch
this video here
and i'll see you there cheers guys